odd Ferguson ten years ago gears of war
two viewed here at the Xbox III briefing
and this year we're taking you back to
where it all began today I'm happy to
announce Gears of War Ultimate Edition
the original Gears of War completely
remastered and modernized for Xbox one
and coming August 25th it's the first at
its best fully rebuilt in 1080p loaded
with new content and 60 frames per
second and multiplayer and you can play
that multiplayer early in our one-week
pink public beta that starts today so
tune in to the Xbox daily live from e3
this afternoon to learn more oh yeah and
one more thing I want to give you a
taste of something else for working out
at the coalition thank you xbox one
exclusive world premiere
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
looks like it went this way come on
hey what's picking up no need to worry
just yet and watch it that thing could
be anyone
hey there's water here
yeah sure that's safe that's just
rainwater yeah with stuff floating in it
that's a sin while live
tell me you heard that there it's on the
moon after it
dear me
we're not
there's a gate here coming
don't stop keep going ahead
don't know what now we find out if that
thing's
check it out um
ah
oh gee I'm okay son I think it short out
my flashlight great you're glowing now
let's just get that here
no all right just don't touch the pause
I'm beginning to think we're not the
hunters anymore let's just clear this
courtyard there come on through the door
yeah go
okay you're a big fella you know that's
not
could you some help here
[Music]